ça ne sera pas facile
nous propose
avec ça
maintenant
dans la voiture
où est votre mécène communautaire
Berger
puis avant résonances ou sécurité
pour te décider
Voyons
à tous
Oh
7 l'écho qui consomme un peu plus petit à petit
par Michel
pour rien
nous commençons
c'est là qu'il a attaqué
nous avons senti le gaz
simarro
pense aux systèmes quand on n'a pas de voiture
et
Ouais
cultistes 2
à respirer
et prêt
la construction de l'excès
deuxième
altération sévère
et vous
qu'avec les bas c'était déjà eu mais à tes côtés
lors de l'impression
avec 7
les odeurs
plus loin
En conclusion oui non
[Musique]
je
exceptionnel
comme je suis
et donc
le cuisinier en 52
Je ne sais pas si nous devons sortir, nous devons tous le faire
appuyer
de sa collection une partie du cheval
pour Excel
si vous êtes
assez de tout le monde
[Musique]
et ils ne sont plus végétariens
toi
le bien a dit
éfe
Ouais
Monsieur
oui jamais moins
mais pour ça
et ainsi?
suivre un régime
pour cela
parce que
Je sais
les gens de Vélez se débarrassent
et a gagné
les fils
si tu souffres
et le dégoût
je porte
Ça existe
l'oeil
deux de ses premiers blocs
de l'assainissement
les archives de l'herbe sterling
Yo
moi aussi
si tu le fais
Donc
et
Père Carlos en direct
étape 5
Ça existe
jolis moules
tandis que nous commençons à verser du sang
incubation nous sommes des raisons
Des terrains disciplinés s'enfuient à des millions
lapins ton nombre de familles
Oh
augmenter le service au fil du temps
propre
tout
[Musique]
la douleur
le ciel est excessivement protecteur
Yo
nous souhaitons
et tous
ensuite
est devenu visible
nous n'avons pas fait les réalisateurs
Ouais
nous sommes difficiles et les codes
lors de la division
d
C'est pourquoi ils trouvent généralement cela utile
et
où une personne existe localement ne sont pas
de la manifestation de l'attention où le
rainure
ou non
[Musique]
parce que ce sont des décisions
et j'y suis allé
moi non
peut supprimer
Oh
et accompagné
a réussi à être moins
et fais-le
et qu'ils sont comme ça et ne sont pas vos partenaires
tecate
ressentir de l'attention
la lumière
maintenant qu'il a
d
Ouais
est le signe
phase
ces barils
et ils savent où nous sommes
tu me dis
après cela
le prochain décide de le faire ici
Yo
Ouais
il est tard
moi, j'étais
Samedi
je sais que c'est parfait
rivaux pour absolument aucun
enveloppe dérivée de San Luis
construisons donc cette vision
différent
par un
tout tout
oui nos maîtres
on y va pour tout le monde et seulement après avoir attendu
peut être possible
mais nous y allons
épaules
des années 80
[Musique]
d
Ouais
je suis
où ces choses
l'asturien
nous sommes ici
mais
une vis
à ce stade
c'est moi
moins
lafon
portes
Ouais
l'accélération est triste
oiseaux
si nous sommes le cou
un froid
fin
gelé
barboza
Ouais
nous l'avons pour l'avenir
éfe
ses dents
et donc je l'enlève
gonzález
tu dois le faire plusieurs fois
mais ils sont hier
être tout cela n'existe pas si nous ne le sommes pas
confiant